Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass, die Standard-Situationen. Sie waren ein begleitendes Thema rund bei dieser Weltmeisterschaft 2018. Darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit Florian Bruns, dem Co-Trainer beim SC Freiburg, der unter anderem Spezialist für Standard-Situationen ist. Guten Tag Herr Bruns, schön, dass Sie mal im Rasenfunk sind. Ja, sehr schön. Erste Podcast-Aufnahme. Wir wollen heute ein bisschen über ein spezielles Thema sprechen, was diese WM aufgebracht hat. Was mich aber erst mal zu der vorgelagerten Frage bringt, wie viel Zeit haben Sie denn als Co-Trainer bei einem Bundesligisten überhaupt, um neben dem Trainingsauftakt, der jetzt letzten Montag war, noch die WM zu verfolgen?
Ja, es war doch genügend Zeit, ehrlich gesagt. Die WM ist ja angefangen, als wir noch in der Sommerpause waren. Das heißt, wir hatten ein bisschen Urlaub und da war es immer mal möglich, mit Familie und Freunden dann die für uns wichtigen Spiele gemeinsam anzugucken, mitzufiebern und am Ende der WM. Als es dann Richtung Viertelfinale, Halbfinale, Endspiele ging, da war ich dann schon immer vom Fernseher gefesselt. Gut.
Und jetzt habe ich schon mehrfach über sie gelesen, dass sie ein Spezialist für Standessituationen sein sollen. Das hat man bei Werder Bremen gesehen und dann später jetzt auch beim SC Freiburg. Stimmt das denn überhaupt? Ist das so ein Fable von Ihnen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob jetzt Spezialist der richtige Ausdruck dafür ist, aber das stimmt, dass ich mich in Bremen schon damit auseinandergesetzt habe und das in meinen Aufgabenbereich ging. Beim SC Freiburg ist es wieder eine der Aufgaben, aber ich mache es nicht komplett alleine, sondern wir machen das wirklich dann auch im Team, mit Lars Fossler und mit Patrick Bayer in Absprache, auch mit Christian Streich. Das ist eher so eine Teamarbeit, aber es ist schon richtig, dass ich mich damit sehr viel die Woche über auseinandersetze und die Gegnersichte und dann auch letztendlich wieder im Team überlege, was können wir da machen.
Warum sind denn Standardsituationen so wichtig im Fußball?
Ja, ich finde oder es ist glaube ich ersichtlich, dass die Mannschaften immer mehr auf Augenhöhe sind. Es gibt immer wieder Spiele, die aufgrund der guten Kompaktheit in der Defensive wirklich sehr eng ausgehen, dass es wirklich, wie ich gerade schon sagte, auf Augenhöhe ist. Und dann ist eine Standardsituation, sei es ein Freistoß um den 16er rum oder auch ein Eckball, 11 Meter sowieso, aber auch ein Einwurf gehört dazu in Nähe des gegnerischen 16ers. Das ist eine gute Möglichkeit, mit einer gut organisierten Variante den Gegner unter Probleme zu setzen und dann auch erfolgreich zu sein.
Und wir wissen, selten waren Tore wertvoller als aktuell jetzt, wo alle Mannschaften so gut im Verteidigen sind. Jetzt sind bei dieser WM unglaublich viele Tore aus Standardsituationen gefallen. 73 von 169 Treffern. Zum Vergleich, bei der WM 2014 waren es noch 38. Das heißt fast eine Verdopplung der Standardtreffer. Viele davon aus Strafstößen, aber eben auch ganz viele aus Ecken und Freistößen. Und nach offizieller FIFA-Zellweise zählen lange Einwürfe noch gar nicht mehr dazu. Ich glaube, sonst hätten wir sogar noch ein paar Tore mehr gesehen. Glauben Sie, das ist jetzt so eine Momentaufnahme? Oder ist das wirklich ein Trend im Fußball, dass die Standardsituationen als Torerzielung, ja, wie jetzt häufiger sehen werden?
Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass der Fokus noch mal dazugekommen ist. Also es galt lange Zeit, dass die Besonderheit im Fußball, dass es ums Umschaltspiel ging, dass man kompakt hinten steht zum Beispiel und dann nach Ball gewinnen, einfach unglaublich schnell nach vorne spielt und dann auch den Gegner von Aufgabe stellt. Und dann, dass Tore schießen einfacher war. Jetzt hat es sich vielleicht ein bisschen gedreht und es geht ganz viel darum, nach Ballverlust alle so schnell wie möglich hinter den Ball zurück, dass es für den Gegner schwer ist, Tore zu machen. Und dann ist dieser Fokus Richtung Standardsituation halt wirklich noch mal dazugekommen. Und ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es in Zukunft bleiben wird. Aber vielleicht werden sich die Mannschaften und die Vereine und die Trainerstäbe, werden sich auch Gedanken machen, wie man dann eben Standardsituationen noch besser verteidigt. Also im Moment ist der der Fokus darauf vielleicht, wie kann ich eine Standardsituation für mich nutzen? Wie kann ich an das Spiel für mich entscheiden? Und dann wird aber sicherlich auch noch dazukommen, wie passiert dann eben gar nichts mehr, dass man eben durch solche Situationen halt auch nicht mehr verliert. Und das ist, das ist glaube ich jetzt schon wirklich eine weitere Sache, die dazukommt.
Was von beiden ist denn einfacher einzustudieren, das Offensive oder das Defensive?
Oh wow, gute Frage. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass beides miteinander zusammenhängt. Also dass sowohl in der Defensive einfach die Positionen, die man dann besetzt mit freien Spielern oder wenn man in Mann-Decke spielt, dass das für alle Spieler einfach ganz klar sein muss. Und damit ist dann schon auch viel geholfen. Aber es kommt halt in beiden Sachen, sowohl offensiv als auch defensiv, auch noch ein Gegner dazu. Das heißt, es werden immer wieder Tore fallen, weil jede Mannschaft sich da wirklich Sachen ausdenkt, vielleicht sogar in Absprache mit den Spielern wirklich austüftelt, wie man den jeweiligen Gegner damit überlisten kann. Und dadurch ist es, glaube ich, kann man es nicht sagen, was wirklich einfacher ist oder schwieriger ist.
Aus der Leihensicht hätte ich gesagt, dass Offensive hat den Vorteil, dass man da in der Aktion ist und die Abwehrspieler reagieren müssen. Das heißt, die Offensive weiß, wir blocken jetzt Spiele xy-freier. Zum Beispiel sagen wir einfach mal, Harry Maguire wäre diese Spieler. Das hat man ja das ein oder andere Mal gesehen. Und die Defensive kann das höchstens erahnen, aber weiß ja auch noch nicht, wo er dann hinlaufen wird, also wo quasi der Zielkorridor ist, der freigeblockt wird.
Ja, könnte man so sagen. Ich könnte jetzt direkt sagen, okay, dann nehme ich den Maguire gar nicht mehr in Manndeckung, sondern ich stelle jetzt eine Raumdeckung auf, wo alle elf Spieler im Raum stehen und für einen Raum zuständig sind. Und dann interessiert mich defensiv gar nicht mehr, wer blockt den frei, sondern da sind dann Blocks gar nicht mehr möglich, weil wirklich so eine Art Zielzone der defensiven Mannschaft einfach abgedeckt ist. Und da muss es dann natürlich in den Luftzweig kämpfen, muss es dann knallen. Und also man muss wirklich gucken, was macht der Gegner? Genau, die Engländer, die sich dann in einer Reihe aufgereiht haben in Sechzehner und aus dieser Situation, wo gar keine Gegenspieler sich dazwischen stellen konnten, sind sie dann ausgeschwärmt in alle Richtungen. Und genau, der Zielspieler war dann der Maguire, der eine Größe hat, der kräftig ist. Und da ist dann im 1 gegen 1, wenn man nicht weiß, in welche Richtung der ausschwärmt, ist es einfach unglaublich schwer, den zu verteidigen. Und da muss man sich dann eine defensive Strategie überlegen, um da dann gegen anzugehen. Und da ist, glaube ich, sehr, sehr viel möglich.
Können Sie mir erklären, warum die meisten Gegner Englands das nicht mit einer Raumendeckung gemacht haben, sondern oft sah ein bisschen aus, als würden alle 20 Feldspieler beim Bus anstehen, erst die Engländer und dann davor die Gegner immer wieder haben, welche versucht sich innerhalb dieser englischen Reihe einzugliedern. Da gab es dann viel Toho Wabohu, auch mit dem Schiedsrichter. Warum haben so wenige Mannschaften dann gesagt, okay, wir spielen jetzt einfach konsequent eine Raumendeckung, weil egal wohin die dann alle ausschwärmen, wenn wir es gut machen, dann haben wir auf jeden Fall jemanden dahin, wo der Ball kommt.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich dann den Vorschlag so gemacht hätte, wenn das jetzt ein Gegenspieler von uns wäre. Weil auch in der Bundesliga gibt es ja wirklich groß gewachsene Spieler, wenn ich mich erinnere, gegen Bayern München, wenn dann ein Süle, ein Boat hängen da oft auf den Hummel. Man muss dann überzeugt auch von der eigenen Mannschaft sein, wenn man dann sagt, hey, wir haben so gute Spieler im 1 gegen 1, in der Defensie, auch auf dem Platz, dann bleibt man wahrscheinlich auch dabei und sagt, nee, wir machen Mannendeckungen. Es geht dann wirklich darum, den Gegner sich in den Weg zu stellen, den Körper einzusetzen, sich in den Luft-Zweikampf dann wirklich auch zu behaupten. Wenn ich das nicht habe, wenn ich der Meinung bin, okay, der Gegner ist uns vielleicht überlegen in diesen 1 gegen 1-Situationen im Sechzehner bei Standard, dann sollte man überlegen vielleicht, okay, vielleicht gehen wir in die Raumdeckung, dann ist jeder Raum in Anführungszeichen besetzt.
Haben Sie da ein präferiertes Modell? Also es gibt ja auch Mischformen, dass man einige Spieler in Mannendeckung nimmt und den Rest im Raum deckt. Felix Magath hat mal gesagt, er hat bei gegnerischen Ecken immer Raumdeckung verteidigen lassen, weil dann der Konter der eigene Mannschaft nach Ballgewinn systematischer gefahren werden konnte.
Okay, ich präferiere tatsächlich, oder was heißt ich präferiere, man kann es ja so allgemein gar nicht sagen, wir haben, um auf die vergangene Saison zurückzukommen mal kurz, wir haben eher Mannendeckung gespielt, weil wir wirklich auch gute Spieler hatten, die in den 1 gegen 1 Situationen da wirklich sehr erfolgreich und gut waren und aufgeboten waren, aber wir haben auch, ich würde jetzt mal tippen, ohne es genau zu wissen, drei, vier Mal es vor den Spielen so besprochen, dass wir im Raum auf den Gegner warten, dass wir da dann versuchen, den Raum zu verteidigen. Also wir sind da so ein bisschen geswitcht hin und her zwischen Raum und Mannendeckung, aber ganz klar, wir haben bestimmt 80 Prozent der Spiele in einer Mannendeckung gemacht und der Vorschlag von Felix Magath klingt erstmal plausibel, aber wir haben dann doch erst mal daran gedacht, in erster Linie geht es darum, das Torf zu verteidigen. Also wir haben jetzt noch nicht im ersten Schritt daran gedacht, okay, wenn wir dann den Ball gewinnen, dass wir dann auch kontern können oder dass wir dann den Angriff einleiten können, sondern bei uns ist in erster Linie dann der Gedanke gewesen, okay, der Gegner hat jetzt eine Standardsituation offensiv und wir sind im eigenen 16er, jetzt geht es darum, auf Teufel komm raus, keinen Gegentor zu bekommen. Damit sind wir eigentlich bisher in der letzten Saison ganz gut gefahren und jetzt geht die ganze, diese Gedankenspiele gehen jetzt natürlich wieder los, was machen wir in der neuen Saison, wie sind die Gegner aufgestellt, es werden sich viele Mannschaften jetzt noch mehr mit den Standardsituationen auseinandersetzen, wie auch schon einige Träne angedeutet haben und das wird eine schöne Herausforderung.
Meinen Sie, wir werden dann so zum Beispiel das englische Modell, weil es eben einfach so erfolgreich war, also 9 seiner 12 Tore hat England nach Standards erzielt bei dieser WM, werden wir das häufiger sehen, es ist ja aufgefallen, dass sogar im WM-Finale Frankreich das dann auch mal bei einer Ecke so gemacht hat, obwohl man also aus meiner Sicht gar nicht so wirklich sehen konnte, ob die wussten, wie sie jetzt dann frei blocken sollen, das war eher ja fast schon so, um zu zeigen, hey, wir machen jetzt auch so was Verrücktes, in Anführungszeichen, wie England, was ja eigentlich auch schon länger im Fußball ist, nur lange nicht mehr so konsequent durchgeführt wurde. Glauben Sie, wir werden diese Bushalteschlangen jetzt auch in der Bundesliga dann häufiger sehen?
Das gab es ja sogar schon, also Schalke 04, kann ich mich nicht erinnern, vergangene Saison und auch Hoffenheim, die haben das ab und zu gemacht, Schalke vor allem mit dem Naldo und Nastasic und Benta Lab waren dann da drin, alles groß gewachsene Spieler und wenn du es dann nicht weißt, was macht denn der Naldo jetzt, der fast zwei Meter groß ist, der eine unglaubliche Wucht hat, dann ist das schon verdammt schwer zu verteidigen und genau die Franzosen, vielleicht haben sie ein Stück weit das übernommen, dass sie sich erst mal so aufstellen, weil man einfach auch merkt, der Gegner hat wirklich Probleme, sie wissen halt wirklich nicht, wo diese Kopfballstärksten Spieler hingehen, gehen sie kurz auf den ersten Pfosten oder auf den zweiten Pfosten, Und in Ansätzen war das schon zu sehen vergangene Saison. Und ich denke, ja, weil einige auch gesehen haben, ja, das ist eine Variante, das hat geklappt. Also das könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, ja.
Wie ist denn da dann eigentlich das optimale Timing? Sollten sich die eigenen Spiele erst dann bewegen, wenn der Schütze ganz kurz davor ist, den Ball zu treffen, oder koordiniert man das besser mit dem Anlauf, weil man dann vielleicht noch eine höhere Geschwindigkeit hat und deswegen halt höher zum Kopfball steigen kann zum Beispiel?
Ja, ich glaube, das kann man nicht so ganz vorgeben. Auch wir als Trainer können das nicht vorgeben, hier dann und dann müsste genau loslaufen, sondern da ist dann auch jeder Spieler. Und deswegen trainiert man es halt auch in Absprache mit dem Schützen, der am Ball steht, der ein paar Schritte Anlauf hat. Der Ball ist dann manchmal 30 Meter, bei Eckbällen, weiß ich nicht, 30 Meter unterwegs in der Luft. Bei Freistößen variiert das nochmal. Also da muss jeder Spieler auch wirklich so ein bisschen ein Timing für sich finden, wie viel Anlauf brauche ich, um optimale Höhe beim Absprung zu bekommen. Einige sind ja schon vor dem Torwart und machen dann nur zwei, drei Schritte entgegen und haben dann die optimale Situation. Also da muss man wirklich von Spielertyp zu Spielertyp irgendwie so ein bisschen unterscheiden. Man kann eine Hilfestellung geben, sicherlich wie man selber das sieht, wenn man nur zuguckt, wie der Trainer jetzt oder Co-Trainer. Aber da ist es auch schwierig, zum Beispiel bei uns einen Nils Petersen zu sagen, Nils, mach das bitte so und so, nimm bitte sechs Meter Anlauf und lauf erst los, wenn der Schütze mit dem Fuß am Ball ist. Also das geht nicht. Also da muss wirklich jeder auch mit diesem, wenn du ein Gegner dicht an dir dran hast, ja dann musst du Richtungswechsel drin haben. Da musst du ein bisschen für Chaos sorgen in der gegnerischen Verteidigung. Und das hat dann viel mit Training zu tun. Wie scharf spielt der Schütze den Ball rein? Ist das eher so, keine Ahnung, dass der Ball eher in einen hohen Bogen reinkommt oder eher so englisch gespielt? Das ist eine Abstimmung, dass man, was man im Training gut einstudieren kann.
Und wie viel Zeit geht da in der Trainingsarbeit für, na verloren ist zu viel gesagt, aber wie viel Zeit investieren Sie da?
Auch das kann man, glaube ich, nicht so pauschal sagen. Also wir setzen uns damit auseinander, wir sprechen unter der Woche natürlich mit einzelnen Spielern oder mal in kleinen Gruppen, auch wenn die Spieler Ideen haben. Hier können wir noch mal ein paar Sachen einstudieren, haben wir noch mal 20 Minuten Zeit nach dem Training. Also manchmal ist es sehr viel, zum Beispiel in der englischen Woche, wenn man dann Samstag, Mittwoch, Samstag spielt, dann kann es sein, dass es sogar mal mehr ist, weil man eh nicht so viel Belastung machen kann, sondern dann wird eher im regenerativen Bereich gearbeitet. Aber für ein paar Standardsituationen, dass die Eckballschützen noch mal Bälle spielen, dass noch mal die Spieler, die am Wochenende auch reinlaufen sollen, noch mal fürs Timing, das kann man dann wirklich noch mal gut trainieren. Und wir nehmen aber schon jede Woche auch, ist das ein fester Bestandteil. Also es ist dann nicht mal so, dass in einer Woche keine Standardsituationen trainiert werden, sondern das ist wirklich ein Punkt inhaltlich gesehen in einer ganz normalen Woche.
Und gehören da dann lange Einwürfe mit dazu, die haben Sie vorhin jetzt schon genannt, bei den Standardsituationen?
Ja, manchmal schon. Also wir variieren. Also es muss nicht immer alles abgearbeitet werden jede Woche, dass man dann immer Eckbälle macht und immer Freistöße oder zentrale Freistöße und aus dem Halt fällt und kurz ausgespielte Ecken oder lang reingeschlagene Ecken genauso mit den Einwürfen. Wir machen es immer so ein bisschen abhängig. Was war letzte Woche? Was bringt uns was für den kommenden Gegner? Wie steht der Gegner? Und natürlich kommen dann Einwürfe auch mal in die Amtszug. Und auch da gibt es da gewisse Möglichkeiten, um sich selber was auszudenken, um den Gegner wieder vor einer Aufgabe zu stellen.
Jetzt gibt es ja bei Ekbären immer noch die Frage, kurzen und langen Pfosten, soll man da einen Spieler platzieren? Meistens heißt es in der Berichterstattung, dass die Torhüter das entscheiden. Ist das beim SC Freiburg auch so? Und wie fällt da die Entscheidung aus?
Also bei uns ist es wirklich keine Entscheidung, egal was es ist. Dass einer sich hinstellt und sagt, ich entscheide das, das wird so und so gemacht. Sondern wir sind da wirklich in einem richtig guten Austausch. Natürlich muss der Torwart sich wohlfühlen. Es geht darum, sein Haus zu verteidigen. Dieses Tor, da darf kein Ball rein. Und wenn der natürlich sagt, ich fühle mich am wohlsten, wenn einer am kurzen und am langen Pfosten steht, klar muss es dann diskutiert werden, weil irgendwo fehlen dann natürlich ein bis zwei Leute. Im Rückraum oder in der Mann-Aufnahme oder als freier Spieler. Und das wird dann vorn Nachteile, das wird einfach diskutiert. Mit einem Torwart, mit sogenannten Führungsspielern oder auch mit erfahrenen Spielern, die schon ein paar Jahre auf dem Buckel haben, die sich einfach damit auch auskennen, die ihre eigenen Erfahrungen dann preisgeben. Und da sind wir im Trainerstab nicht so oder auch der Torwart ist dann bei uns nicht so, dass er sagt, ich bin aber der Torwart und ich muss das jetzt entscheiden, weil ich bin dafür verantwortlich, sondern nee, wir alle sind dafür irgendwie verantwortlich und wir wollen das Bestmögliche. Also darf auch jeder, der irgendwie Zweifel oder eine Idee hat in beide Richtungen, darf dann auch einfach sagen, hier, nee, ich finde aber, das ist so und so besser. Und damit sind wir eigentlich auch wirklich ganz gut gefahren.
Ja, ist denn eine gut geschlagene kurze Ecke, nicht kurze Ecke, sondern auf den kurzen Pfosten geschlagene Ecke, ist die überhaupt zu verteidigen? Also Beispiel um TT gegen Belgien im Halbfinale oder sicherlich auch ein Beispiel, was viele Hörerinnen und Hörer auch vor Augen haben, Didier Drogba gegen Bayern im Champions League Finale 2012. Mein Eindruck wäre, wenn der Stürmer da mit hohem Tempo kommt, dann hat er einen solchen Vorteil beim Absprung, dass er einfach an einer Höhe an den Ball kommt. Da kann ein Verteidiger eigentlich vielleicht noch ein bisschen unterlaufen. Vielleicht kommt man halbwegs noch, ob er auf Schulterhöhe hoch ist, aber das ist ja eigentlich kaum zu verteidigen.
Ja.
Warum wird dann nicht jede Ecke so ausgeführt eigentlich?
Also es ist tatsächlich schwierig, wenn der Stürmer sich gut von seinem Gegenspieler löst im Anlauf und dann diesen halben Meter oder einen Meter Vorsprung hat und dann frei hochgehen kann. Also unbehindert praktisch im Anlauf zum Kopfball hochgehen kann. Aber damit geht es ja schon los. Wenn man sich für eine Mann-Deckung entscheidet, dann ist ja der Fokus wirklich darauf, was passiert da gerade? Also der Mann, der dann gegen den Üm-Titi zum Beispiel eingeteilt ist und man in den Aufnahmen vorher gesehen hat, dass er nun mal zu 95 Prozent auf den ersten Pfosten geht, dann kann man sich als Abwehrspieler natürlich auch dementsprechend verhalten. Das heißt, man stellt sich dann schon so zwischen Tor und Gegner und wartet dann praktisch auf diese Auftaktbewegung, um dann den Laufweg aufzunehmen. Das ist erstmal die erste Möglichkeit. Dann ist der nächste Punkt, wenn derjenige frei zum Absprung kommt, dann ist das schon mal auch nicht so gut, weil auch da geht es ja häufig darum, du musst ja nicht am Trikot reißen, oder am Arm ziehen, oder hinten Huckepack raufschieben als Abwehrspieler. Aber es reicht ja schon oft in dem Anlaufweg, wenn man dann hochspringt, dass man leichter gegenspringt, dass man selber hochgeht, den Körper einsetzt, dann kommt er nicht frei zum Absprung und kann den Ball praktisch koordinieren, sondern er kommt auch vielleicht auftritt und aus dem Gleichgewicht und so weiter. Das ist dann nicht immer ein Faul oder ein Elfmeter, sondern das ist einfach, man ist dicht am Gegenspieler dran, man behindert den vielleicht beim Absprung und kann das so auch schon verteidigen. Und dann gibt es noch die freien Spieler. Am ersten Pfosten, jede Mannschaft, wirklich bei Standard-Situationen, hat einen freien Spieler auf Höhe des ersten Pfostens. Und auch der ist natürlich dafür zuständig, nicht nur da irgendwo einfach rumzustehen, sondern die Gegenspieler oder die Spieler, die dann da einlaufen, das so einzuschätzen, dass man auch noch davor kommen könnte. Na ja, und dann kommt auch noch dazu, dass der Ball perfekt gespielt sein muss, was auch nicht so leicht ist. Wenn eine Mannschaft zehn Eckbälle hat, dann ist es utopisch zu sagen, zehn Bälle müssen genau dahin kommen. Und der Offensivspieler muss in zehn Fällen auch von seinem Gegenspieler wegkommen, und der freie Mann hat auch keine Chance. Dann ist es schon sehr schwierig, wenn man das dann statistisch mal festhält, dass da wirklich was passiert. Auch defensiv gibt es Varianten und Möglichkeiten, dagegen zu wirken.
Hat sich denn durch den Videobeweis etwas beim Verteidigen von Eckbällen und Freistößen aus dem Halbwelt verändert? Haben wir jetzt ja auch bei dieser WM gesehen. Es gab Szenen, die wurden gepfiffen. Es gab auch Szenen wie zum Beispiel Serbien gegen Schweiz, die wurden nicht gepfiffen. Aber grundsätzlich weiß man, wenn man seinen Gegenspieler so festhält, dass der ursächlich dadurch zum Fall kommt, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit inzwischen sehr viel höher, einen Strafstoß gegen sich zu bekommen als früher. Gehen Sie darauf ein?
Nein, wir müssen da gar nicht wirklich drauf eingehen, weil das ja auch jeder Spieler selber sieht. Ich glaube, grundsätzlich ist natürlich die Anzahl der Standard-Tore, auch bei der WM, ausschlaggebend gewesen, auch aufgrund der Elfmeter. Natürlich auch Eckbälle und Freistöße, aber die Elfmeter, die dann immer wieder auch gegeben wurden, hat natürlich auch etwas mit dem Videoschützrichter zu tun. Ich glaube, jeder Spieler weiß einfach, ich sollte mich jetzt nicht fünf Sekunden an das Trikot in meines Gegenspielers hängen, weil es wird sowieso gesehen. Dadurch ist natürlich diese Schwierigkeit, eng am Mann zu bleiben, den Körper einzusetzen und so weiter, sehr aufmerksam zu sein. Das ist noch mal wichtiger geworden als vorher. Vorher hast du vielleicht mal einen Moment geschlafen, hast aber den Gegner noch am Arm gehalten, aber es wird nicht geahnt, weil es nicht gesehen wurde. Und jetzt ist es halt wirklich so, es ist ein Eckball, einer kommt zu Fall, der Ball ist geklärt, entweder wieder zur Ecke oder zum Abstoß und dann hat der Schützrichter oder auch die Videoschützrichter haben halt wirklich Zeit, vielleicht 20, 30 Sekunden, sich das schnell noch mal anzugucken. Und wenn da was gesehen wird, dann gibt es halt Elfmeter und das ist, glaube ich, schon auch ein Punkt, der dann bei Eckbällen und Freistößen auch noch dazu kommt.
Okay, aber das heißt, sie geben jetzt nicht, wie ich glaube Thomas Tuchel war es, der seinen Spielern Tennisbälle in die Hand gegeben hat, damit sie versuchen zu verteidigen, ohne am Trikot zu ziehen, sowas machen sie jetzt nicht in Freiburg auch.
Wow, gute Idee, nee, haben wir noch nicht, aber wir sind ja für alle Sachen immer offen.
Sagen sie bitte, es kommt von mir und nicht von Thomas Tuchel.
Ja, genau, ich werde auf jeden Fall mal das so gleich weitergeben in der Trainerkabine. Damit haben wir uns tatsächlich so noch nicht auseinandergesetzt, sondern die Spieler wissen das. Natürlich ist es auch menschlich, wenn du die Verantwortung hast für diesen einen Spieler und der entwischt dir, vielleicht ist es dann auch eine Reaktion oder ein Reflex, dass du dann einfach zupacken willst, weil es passiert ja noch, dass da wirklich einer am Trikot zieht und dadurch gibt es dann Elfmeter. Aber alle wissen, warum macht er das denn? Weil es vielleicht ein Reflex ist oder weil er für einen Moment nicht aufmerksam war und dann kommt die Hand da hin. Manchmal kann man es auch hinterher nicht erklären, aber mit den Tennisbällen werde ich das hier mal auf jeden Fall in die Kabine schmeißen.
Sehr gut, dann stelle ich mir auch schön vor, die Tennisbälle erstmal in die Kabine zu schmeißen. Das könnte dann wie beim Montags- spiel zwischen Rasenball-Sport Leipzig und Eintracht Frankfurt aussehen. Ich hoffe, es gibt auch Leute, die das aufsammeln. Geht man denn dann in jedes Spiel, Sie haben es vorhin schon gesagt, dass Sie mit unterschiedlichen Varianten an die unterschiedlichen Gegner rangehen, gibt es dann immer zwei, drei einstudierte Varianten, so ähnlich wie im Playbook im American Football, wo man weiß, okay, gut, das sind jetzt auf diesen Gegner unsere Ideen, wie wir versuchen, aus Standards Tore zu erzielen. Und wer sagt dann auf dem Platz eigentlich an, was probieren wir jetzt?
Ja, irgendwie kann man sich das so vorstellen. Also natürlich nicht irgendwie, dass man jetzt unglaublich viele Varianten hat, sondern man ist natürlich auch so, dass man so zwei, drei Ideen hat oder auch erfolgreich war. Wenn das mal irgendwie geklappt hat, dann bleibt man natürlich dabei und möchte das nochmal versuchen. Aber man versucht dann immer wieder, es zu optimieren. Man guckt sich den Gegner an, guckt, was hat bei uns selber geklappt, was könnten wir machen. Dann testen wir immer ein paar mehr Varianten im Training, als man dann am Wochenende spielt. Guckt sich das im Training an, was funktioniert, was funktioniert nicht und dann legt man sich halt fest. Das ist dann wieder in Absprache mit den Spielern. Was für ein Gefühl habt ihr, was glaubt ihr, ist das möglich, können wir das umsetzen, was ist, wenn der Gegner dabei ist. Und dann muss man wieder, denkt dran, hier Bayern München hat in einer Raumdeckung gespielt und dann sind da solche Riesen drin und solche Spieler wie Hummels, Boateng, Süle, was ich gerade schon mal gesagt hatte. Ist das umsetzbar oder was habt ihr für ein Gefühl? Dann ist man wieder in einer kurzen Diskussion und überlegt sich, was ist machbar. Und dann setzt man es um. Und dann hat man zwei, drei Möglichkeiten und das entscheiden die Spieler dann auf dem Platz. Der Schütze, entweder der Schütze durch gewisse Zeichen oder aber auch die Spieler in der Mitte. Wenn man fünf oder sechs Spieler im Sechzehner hat, dass man dann sagt, hier, zack, so machen wir es. Einmal kurz zusammenkommen, einmal kurz ein Schlagwort geben und dann wissen alle Bescheid. Und das ist tatsächlich immer unterschiedlich und das wird dann vor dem Spiel besprochen.
Haben die gehobenen Arme noch eine Bedeutung? Also der Schütze beim Eckball zum Beispiel hebt den rechten Arm oder beide Arme oder den linken. Oder ist das inzwischen einfach nur noch, um den Gegner zu verwirren?
Unterschiedlich glaube ich. Also bei uns hat es mal eine Bedeutung, mal aber auch nicht. Mal hat es was damit zu tun, wann die Aktion startet. Also der Arm geht dann hoch, wenn die Aktion startet. Manchmal ist es aber auch ein Zeichen für eine Variante. Also da ist es auch wirklich intern innerhalb der Mannschaft eine Absprache. Manche machen es sicherlich auch, um den Gegner zu verwehren. Manchmal heben einige Spieler am Ball außen beide Arme und man denkt, oh, was passiert jetzt? Das passiert aber nicht. Da wird einfach der Ball reingeschlagen. Da könnte ich nur für uns reden, wie wir das machen und nicht für alle, wie man das allgemein macht. Aber da möchte ich auch nicht zu viel verraten. Was wir da planen mit den Armzeichen oder auch eben nicht.
Hey, ich habe Ihnen die Tennisballidee gegeben. Da können Sie doch jetzt... Aber zu den gehobenen Armen kann ich nur sagen, Ajan Robben zum Beispiel hebt immer den linken Arm. Und meiner Meinung nach ist das nur noch, damit auch wirklich jetzt alle die Konzentration hoch haben, dass er sagt, hier, ich schieße jetzt voll wirklich. Und wir führen nicht wie früher unter Pep Guardiola alles kurz aus, sondern der kommt jetzt noch in, bitte alle mal aufgemacht. Es gab mal unter Christoph Daum war das, glaube ich, als er in seiner Kölner Zeit Trainer war. Da haben die Kölner in einem Spiel drei Tore mit einer Eckballvariante auf den kurzen Pfosten geschlagen und später wurde das thematisiert, dass er in Zeiten, in denen das noch nicht so digitalisiert war, alles eben entdeckt hat, dass der Gegner immer da eine Lücke hat im Abwehrverbund und deswegen hat er jede Ecke da reinschlagen lassen. Das ist jetzt so wahrscheinlich nicht mehr möglich. Jetzt kommt ja zur neuen Saison noch mit dazu, dass man jetzt auch technische Hilfsmittel in der Coaching Area verwenden darf und man darf auch kommunizieren mit jemandem, der im Stadion-Innenraum auf der Tribüne sich aufhält. Glauben Sie, dass das auch dafür eingesetzt wird, dass man Varianten schnell erkennt, dass man vielleicht auch schneller sehen kann, was hat sich der Gegner überlegt bei Standard-Situationen und darauf dann reagiert? Oder ist das jetzt so eine Leihensicht von mir und Sie haben das sowieso immer unten in der Bank im Blick und die Spieler reagieren da auf dem Feld auch selber schon drauf? Sehr gut.
Nein, es ist natürlich irgendwie auch wieder ein Zusammenspiel. Also, wie auf der Trainerbank, gucken natürlich genau hin bei Standard-Situationen auch, wie steht der Gegner jetzt tatsächlich. Also man kann ja teilweise, als Beispiel, man beobachtet RB Leipzig und guckt sich das genau an. Und die letzten sechs Spiele haben sie immer in einer Raumdeckung gespielt und so weiter und so weiter. Und auf einmal haben wir unseren ersten Eckball und sie machen eine Mannendeckung. Das ist natürlich eigentlich alles, was man vielleicht selber sich überlegt hat, ist halt nicht mehr möglich. So und dann geht es halt darum, auch einen kreativen Moment zu haben. Also dann sind ja unsere Spieler auch frei in ihren Möglichkeiten und zu sagen, f**k, jetzt spielen wir mal einen kurzen. Also dann kommt einer entgegen und wir spielen, eine Ecke wird kurz ausgeführt. Ja und dann ergeben sich neue Laufwege in der Mitte vom Tor und so weiter und so weiter. Und genauso ist es umgekehrt, dass man sagt, okay, der Gegner macht das so und so und jetzt können wir vielleicht das und das noch machen. Dann geht man in der Halbzeitpause kurz darauf ein, gibt dann den Hinweis und dann setzt die Mannschaft das wieder um. Also es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten, sowohl die Spieler sind da in der Verantwortung, Ideen zu haben und auch kreativ zu sein in der jeweiligen Situation. Und wir können natürlich auch von draußen einwirken. Dann wahrscheinlich ist es dann erst in der Halbzeitpause, weil die Spieler alle kurz zusammenzurufen und zu sagen, wir machen jetzt eine andere Variante, eher schwierig.
Eher schwierig. Vielleicht wie im American Football machen, wo man dann irgendwelche Zeichen hochhält, dann ist da eine goldene Erdbeere und dann wissen alle auf dem Platz Bescheid. In der letzten Saison hat der SC Freiburg 11 Tore nach Standard-Situationen erzielt, auch 11 kassiert, 6 dann noch nach Strafschluss. Da erinnern wir uns vor allem an Nils Petersen. Jetzt hätte ich gerne harte Fakten, wie viele Tore nach Standard-Situationen werden es in der nächsten Saison sein?
Und daran werden wir dann gemessen?
Natürlich, da bin ich knallhart.
Keine Ahnung, man möchte sich ja immer verbessern. Ich hatte auf dem Zettel, dass wir 18 Standard-Tore geschossen haben.
Wenn man die Strafschlüsse dazu rechnet. Ich komme hier mit meiner Zählweise auf 17, aber ich vertraue mal Ihren 18, Sie sind näher dran.
Genau, ich war mir ziemlich sicher, dass es 18 waren und irgendwie möchte man sich ja immer verbessern. Alles, was dann mehr als 18 Tore sind, wäre großartig, aber ich weiß halt auch, dass das nicht immer möglich ist. Also wenn man sich jedes Jahr in allen Bereichen überall verbessern möchte, dann ist das verdammt gut. Aber natürlich nehmen wir das jetzt nicht als Ziel, wir müssen jetzt 19 Tore machen, aber natürlich möchte man das irgendwie bestätigt haben und wird alles daran setzen, dass wir wieder gefährlich sind bei eigenen Standards und dass wir es auch schaffen, gegnerische Standards gut zu verteidigen und werden uns da wieder, werden wir da wieder die Köpfe zusammenstecken, um vielleicht noch einen drauf zu setzen. Aber versprechen kann man es natürlich nicht, weil da gehört ja auch ein Gegner mit dazu.
Sie sind einfach jemand, der bei einem Bundesligisten arbeitet, die lassen sich nie auf genauer Vorhersagen festnageln. Das ist aber auch völlig okay. Auf jeden Fall haben Sie es geschafft, dass jetzt vermutlich bei vielen Freiburger Standard-Situationen meine Hörerinnen und Hörer an Sie denken werden. Vielen Dank, Herr Bruns, dass Sie sich die Zeit genommen haben für den Rasenfunk. Hat großen Spaß gemacht. Und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für die Aufmerksamkeit. Das war der vorletzte aller WM-Kurzpässe. Morgen gibt es noch einen neuen und weiterhin gilt. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe- und sponsorenfrei, rein Hörerinnen und Hörer finanziert. Wer wissen möchte, wie man uns unterstützen kann, erfährt das auf rasenfunk.de. Und dann freue ich mich, wenn ihr morgen wieder den nächsten Kurzpass hört und alle fleißig Standardsituationen übt. Bis morgen, macht's gut, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.